[Music]
we're going to look at one of the most
important touching points that there is
in the human endeavor which is a
relationship between imagination and
creativity in the real world that we
touch so uncovering reality is all about
looking at whether science really does
describe reality or how much of it's in
our heads my briefs earth physics
depends on the correspondence between
mathematical laws and the worlds the
question we want to address here is does
it all the models that we use powerful
tools or do they actually exist out
there in nature and how much of our
description of the universe actually
enables us to understand what's really
there
firstly let me just make a confession
physics and physicists are pretty
limited in the kinds of things we can
describe or at least describe usefully
you know when things get too complicated
we just we kind of get a bit scared we
can't solve the equations we don't
really know what what to do you know
anything on the level of human
interactions or problems in society I
need anything that's just just hard
we're not good at solving um what we
good at is when we can find situations
where you can sweep away those
complications and you can focus in on
you know the essence of something so try
to isolate something and that's where we
can really make progress so there's sort
of a two pronged attack we have on
understanding the world the first I
guess is what you would call fundamental
physics so it's where you just look at
smaller and smaller distance scales and
try to understand what everything's made
of and then what that stuff does that's
sort of the the first approach and I
think on this level physics has just
been spectacularly successful this is a
story of you know atoms in the periodic
table or in the more modern perspective
particle physics and what's called the
standard model it's a best theory for
everything that we have and you know
these theories are just just amazing we
have the standard model we've had it for
30 years it survived everything we've
thrown at it it predicts correctly every
single experiment that we've been able
to do and very often with an accuracy
that's just unprecedented in any other
field of human endeavor you know two to
nine decimal places nine digits after
the decimal point will do the
calculations and not just just be right
so this is just very very impressive
okay so that's the first approach of
physics the second approach is actually
what most physicists do most of the time
which is try to work backwards so try to
start with those building blocks that
that we've discovered typically atoms
and electrons and then try to work some
up
the hierarchy to understand all the
things that we missed in our rush to get
to the very bottom um so here I think
it's a little more of a mixed bag you
know it's hard to do that in particular
because what happens is is you find that
when you take billions of particles and
you put them together
the exhibit phenomena that you don't see
for a single particle the exhibit what's
called emergent phenomena you get
collective behavior with all of these
particles cooperating together to give
rise to new building blocks on the next
level we probably wouldn't have thought
of
there's only not obvious by looking at
the fundamental laws of physics so here
as I said you know things are you know a
little more rocky there's some areas of
science that I think we've just nailed
chemistry chemistry can basically be
understood in terms of physics and
understood of a quantitative level
material science is what's called
condensed matter physics but
understanding you know what why the wood
looks like it does why the light shines
off the glass but not off the woods it's
things like this why why metals conducts
electricity again just we've nailed it
but then as things start to get Messier
you get to molecular biology we start to
struggle as we get to cellular biology
where we're really in trouble you move
up and you get to physiology or human
psychology or social sciences you know
we're really way out of our depth here
so that that's sort of a global vision
of physics it's limited in what it can
say about the world but when it's good
it's just really really good when you're
in the realm where physics is effective
I just think there's no other game in
town this is this is far and away the
best thing that we have to describe
reality at those levels
I understood that this is we have to
describe reality and this was really the
reason why I'm kind of I mean scientists
because the whole idea of being a
scientist if I understand what's going
on this is what I get out of my work
this is my purpose and I if I go too
deep down and see quarks and see
standard model I see we have as we said
it's beautifully correct when I go to a
language of mathematics it's very
elegant it's very simple but my main
work is foundations of quantum mechanics
it's when I start to use these basic
laws of physics which worked perfectly
for very small systems and try to go up
now there are this chemistry biology
whatever when we can use physics and try
to explain things and thinks I'm messy
and I don't know exactly what's going on
but I tend to believe that it will work
fine what I'm looking for being in
foundations and this there is such an
area's foundations of quantum mechanics
foundations of physics today is the
places where there are paradoxes
sometimes you take this basic simple
laws you apply them and you can apply
them to a system which you can really
see and you get to a paradoxes this is
situation when we consider like you
mentioned this interaction free
measurements I'm trying to find an
object without touching it it's
contradict our common sense in my work
I'm looking for paradoxes but not a to
find the nature is strange I'm looking
to current access to solve them because
my final
to get the complete simple explanation
and I believe that there is one I have
to admit that the position which I have
about reality it's not what we usually
see around I believe that the reality is
is not kind of strong object as we see
here the reality everything is waved
this is the only way where you can have
a theory which I can understand
everything everything is just wave wave
which have interference and moreover
it's a quantum wave quantum have not
more just interference it has
entanglement like different particles
can be entangled and interfere only when
they are together I have to pay a price
which I mentioned in the two hours ago
when I talked about causality because
explain reality explain causality to get
a correct explanation of this picture I
have to admit that what I see here it's
not the only thing which there is there
there should be some many parallel
worlds and which maybe I'm not here and
you didn't come to this festival now
it's not ever it's not that everything
exists sometimes I can make things to
split in my home page I have a world
splitter you can take my name look on
internet go to world splitter and make a
split split or word to any and from 2 to
6 and then you decide where you go every
time and you will be shared that sum of
sum of copies you will go to all these
places I believe in all these strange
things because I want to have a simple
explanation of everything which I see
and I believe that today's physics has a
very good explanation on what we see
around we understand there are people
like you working and string theory and
other things these are things which you
cannot really measure now we also want
to understand the beginning of the
universe in the end I believe that there
will be no more evolutions when you
finish your job
I believe that now roughly we understand
everything which is around
on one hand I'm in the lion's den here
with the two realist scientists but in
some ways I don't differ in terms of
what I would be wanting to do from what
lived I said I would be wanting to
describe how the world is and say as
much about what is going on as we can
and that's what I understood philosophy
to be attempting to do so we start from
some common ground however the
scientific theories like all of our
accounts of the world are created by the
mind and that I guess we can all agree
but I don't think that they describe the
world itself I think they are ways that
we use to make sense of the world and to
intervene and their enormous ly powerful
and successful but I don't think that in
some sense they say how it is another
Bates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of Arts and
ideas at IAI TV
you